hey GameSpot I'm going to show you
project Argo give a few thoughts on what
it is and where it's going and then
leave you with some gameplay we love
tactical shooters here at GameSpot so
keep up those likes and subs and we'll
bring you more project Argo is a
free-to-play standalone ARMA project
currently with PvP modes you can get in
early by going to the project argo page
and linking to Steam project Argo is an
interesting experiment to see if a
complex war sandbox title that spun off
successful mods and stand-alones like
player knowns battlegrounds can become
friendly enough to compete with their
own offspring we put in a couple of
hours and so far it does accomplish
making Armas tactical appeal a lot more
friendly for a wider audience
it does this largely by simplifying
Armas complex control scheme and honing
maps down to smaller sizes and clear
understandable objectives new players
should go right to the link game-mode in
which teams buy back and forth to
capture and hold a series of uplink
points in this mode respawns are enabled
so you can quickly learn the feel of
this game project Argo also has a
surprising amount of cosmetic
customization and a skill unlock tree to
get the attachments armor and grenades
that veteran players prefer plus a
shooting range to test everything out
while fun and I must stress in
development Argo still needs to shake
some of Armas larger barriers that make
it hard for a mass audience to take to
mainly no easy friend foe recognition
and still overly complex controls that
seem more obsessed with stances than
smooth gunplay to be fair key remapping
can fix some of this agro has stiff
competition with newer titles like
player knowns battlegrounds escape from
tarkov squad and insurgency but people
who come to these games for more
realistic gunplay bullet physics and
reality inspired themes may find what
they're looking for plus you know it's
free my question to you is whether a
game like ARMA should become more
appealing to gamers or is what makes arm
so special the kind of organic stuff a
guy like shack tactical taps into on
youtube let's have the discussion as
this game develops in the comments below
and thanks for watching
come on support the capture one step
down keep up the good work
watch the timer there's only half the
time left
hariya you're almost out fine
the airdrop is here keep an eye on it